-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show"!
I'm here with Tariq Trotter
from The Roots, everybody.
Come on.
[ Cheering and applause ]
We're about to play a game
of "Catchphrase,"
but we're going
to need some partners.
[ Door closes ]
Joining my team is the star
of the upcoming holiday movie
"Spirited,"
premiering in theaters
this Friday
and globally on Apple TV+
November 18th.
Give it up for Octavia Spencer!
[ Rimshot ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
My partner!
I'm so happy to see you!
Let's get that win!
-[Indistinct]
-Hey.
-Get that win.
-Alright.
-Tariq, your partner stars
in the upcoming movie
"The Fabelmans," opening
in New York and L.A.
this Friday,
and theaters everywhere
November 23rd.
Please welcome Seth Rogen,
ladies and gentlemen!
[ Rimshot ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Yes! [Indistinct], baby.
-Wow.
-Whoo!
-Coming in hot.
Coming in --
Coming in confident!
Coming in hot!
-Coming in hot.
-Why not, why not?
-Here's how the game works.
I'm going to start the round
by pressing start
on this buzzer.
And, Seth, you're going to draw
a clue from the top of the pile.
You're going to have
to get your partner
to guess the clue
as quickly as possible,
then hand the buzzer
to the person on your right.
If you're holding the buzzer
when it goes off,
your team loses that round.
[ Laughter ]
We're going to play
three rounds.
Let's take our positions.
-Alright, alright.
-Alright, here we go.
-You're on the other side.
-I'm on the other side?
-Yeah, here we go. Come on, bud.
-Alright, okay. Oh, I'm nervous.
-Alright, here we go.
Come on, we got it.
-I'm ready!
-Unh-unh.
-1, 2, 3, go.
-Alright.
[ Beeping ]
-He's the old guy
from "A Christmas Carol."
The main character.
-Oh, Ebenezer Scrooge.
-Yes!
-Wow!
-Aah aah!
Ooh, ah!
[ Rapid beeping ]
Okay, it's not a sweater,
but it goes --
-A cape!
-But it goes up closer
to your head.
It --
-Hoodie.
-No, but it's -- it's w--
It's something --
It's --
-Uh! Oh, God!
Uh uh uh uh.
-It's also like an animal.
Like a -- has a shell.
Uh, turtleneck!
-Yes!
-Aha!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Wow.
-Sometimes they put
this fish on pizza.
-Anchovies!
-Right.
-Oh, wow!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Uh!
-Yes!
[ Rapid beeping ]
-You hit it when you wake up
in the morning.
-Alarm -- snooze!
-Yes!
-Snooze button.
-Yeah, ooh!
[ Rapid beeping ]
-They're a rubber shoe --
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
-Ooh, my favorite
Beatles album.
-Yep, it's a good one.
-Rubber shoe.
-Rubber shoe -- a sneaker?
-Yeah, a rubber shoe.
-Yeah, that was a good one.
I liked that clue.
-No, it was a brand.
It's a brand.
-Oh, it's Crocs.
-Oh! Okay.
-That is a rubber shoe.
That was good.
Seth, that was a good clue.
Alright, Octavia,
we got the point there, okay?
-Alright, alright, alright.
-But your chance to tie it
right here, Seth, again,
when you're ready.
-I'm ready.
I get it now. I'm good.
1, 2, 3, go!
You bounce on it like this.
It's an olden toy
from days of yore.
-Inchworm.
-No, it's like, you know.
-Bouncy ball!
-No, it has an elongated middle
and two things on the side.
-Uh, uh --
What is that thing called?
-I know! It's a weird name.
-Uh, uh --
-And then people
-jumpy Jack.
-sort of like corn dogs
with a similar name, I think.
-Oh! Uhhh!
Ping po-- [ Mumbling ]
-It's not like, uhh --
-Oh, jeez!
-You know, it's --
I don't know.
You know what it is!
You just don't know the word!
-I do! I do! What is it?
-I don't know what to do
in this situation.
I've done my job.
[Indistinct]
I'm going to take this win.
-[ Laughs ]
-Alright, [indistinct].
A dog catches a...?
-Get outta here.
[ Laughter ]
[ Rapid beeping ]
-There's a sandwich shop.
Can I do rhymes with?
-Yeah.
-Rhymes with a sandwich shop.
It's a bad L.A. sandwich.
-What do you throw
at like a dog?
You throw a ball
and you throw a...?
[ Buzzer ]
-What?!
[ Sad trombone plays ]
You throw a bone?
What?!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-It's a pogo stick!
[ Rimshot ]
-Ah, damn it!
[ Sad trombone plays ]
Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
It's a pogo stick.
-It's a pogo stick!
-Yeah.
Once you don't get this,
there's nowhere to go.
[ Laughter ]
There's nowhere to go.
Nowhere to go.
Makes it worse.
It makes it worse.
-The conveyance of the thing
wasn't the problem.
-I'm just hearing
from the judges right now
that we're going to play
one more round
-We got to play another round.
-and this round is worth
1,000 points.
-Ohh!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Wins the whole thing.
Wins the whole thing.
Here we go.
-Here we go.
-Seth, whenever you're ready.
-Worked myself up here.
Okay.
1, 2, 3.
[ Beeping ]
You sit on it.
It makes a fart noise.
-Uh, uh, uh --
-It's a balloon toy
-Hot air balloon.
[ Laughter ]
-you sit on and it makes
a fart noise.
I'd say it's
in the same universe
as a pogo stick, honestly.
-It's another dumbass name.
[ Laughter ]
What is it?
There's a pie with the same --
-Ah, [bleep].
A little cake.
-Whoopee, a whoopee cushion.
Whoopee cushion.
-Oh, my God!
Wow!
-Yes!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Okay.
Elon Musk now owns it.
-Twitter!
-Yes.
-Oh, my God.
-What?!
-Um, uh, uh, it's an instrument.
You hold it in your hand
and it's --
-Kazoo.
-Yes.
-Ah!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-You go around the board
with it.
-Sorry, Monopoly.
-Yes!
[ Cymbals crash ]
[ Rapid beeping ]
-It's a disc of dough
and it comes --
-A pizza.
-Cold dough.
-A pie, pizza pie.
-You buy it cold.
-DiGiorno's, frozen pizza.
-Yes!
-Aah!
[ Applause ]
-The little yellow cartoons.
-Minions!
-Yes!
[ Cymbals crash ]
[ Rapid beeping ]
-You put it a burger,
a burger.
It's red!
[ Buzzer ]
-Ketchup?
-Yes, yes, yes!
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
[ Sad trombone plays ]
-Wow!
"You put it on a burger.
It's red."
[Indistinct], man.
-Was it ketchup?
-Yes, yeah.
-Thanks to Octavia Spencer,
the champs.
[Indistinct] champion.
Seth Rogen,
thank you for being here.
We appreciate it.
Tariq Trotter,
thank you for playing.
We're talking to Octavia
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.